[Música]
buenas tardes
acabo de tocar precisamente el ejército
mexicano un fragmento que hizo que
decidiera ser guitarrista cuando tenía
10 años les confieso que desde hace 15
años que no toco esta pieza y después de
grabarla en 2004 en un disco pero hay
obras que jamás se olvida
y bueno estoy aquí quizá porque no hay
muchas mujeres guitarristas
maestros de guitarra eran puros hombres
la mayoría de mis alumnos son hombres
actualmente el abad no tengo ni una
alumna aunque curiosamente recientemente
en un concurso interno de guitarra del
abad lo ganó una mujer y hay muchos
ejemplos como este de mujeres que se han
destacado en el campo de la guitarra que
motivan e inspiran a más mujeres niñas y
jóvenes que estudian este instrumento en
diferentes países organizan diferentes
festivales dedicados a la mujer a la
guitarra a la mujer y tuve el honor de
participar en costa rica en 2000 en uno
de estos eventos que reunió a más de 30
mujeres guitarristas de todo el mundo y
después fue en paraguay en francia aquí
en méxico también hay muchos eventos de
música dedicados a la mujer
en 2005 también invité a siete mujeres
guitarristas conmigo éramos ocho para
conmemorar el día internacional de la
mujer y clausurar el festival de
guitarra que organizó aquí en puebla
desde 1999
con experiencia inolvidable
empecé a dar clases muy joven cuando
tenía 16 años mientras estaba estudiando
estaba trabajando en una escuela de
música igualmente mis alumnos eran
hombres y todos eran mayores que yo yo
quería
pensarán que yo tenía 23 años que no
supieron mi edad me vestía siempre de
saco muy seria y tenía una alumna y el
director de la escuela me había dicho
que el oso le había pisado el oído es
una expresión en rusia que utilizan para
describir a las personas que no tienen
nada de habilidad musical o sea no
tienen nada de oído
sin embargo unos meses después el mismo
director estaba sorprendido al verla
tocar en un concierto con una gran
capacidad musical y habilidad técnica
es más fue una estrella aquella noche
jamás olvidaré el brillo de sus ojos que
me llenaban de felicidad lamentablemente
un año después tuvo que dejar la escuela
porque había entrado a una organización
concertista de moscú llamada arroz
concert y con un grupo teatral
realizamos numerosas giras por toda
rusia con espectáculos musicales sobre
la vida y obra de grandes poetas hay que
decir que en rusia es una gran tradición
leer la poesía y visitarla de memoria
así como llevar a los niños pequeños a
muchos talleres para que descubran lo
que más les gusta así me tocó estudiar
ballet por supuesto música astronomía
taller de creación literaria gastronomía
costura y muchos talleres más hasta
teatro también estudié cinco años hasta
que a los 13 años decidí quedarme
solamente
la música
nunca me imaginé que a través de esta
obra de manuel m ponce hizo que
decidiera ser guitarrista y méjico algún
día fuera mi país
estas experiencias
no sabía que estas experiencias me
llevarían algún día a nivel de posgrado
realizar investigaciones sobre la crisis
musical la transposición de una obra
literaria al plano musical y más tarde
abordar el tema del desarrollo de la
creatividad a partir del cuento
jamás imaginé que
me iría de mosco de este vida tan
intensa muchos conciertos viajamos por
toda rusia e incluso fuimos a chernóbil
después de este accidente nuclear de
1986 yo tenía 17 años en nuestro grupo
había una actriz
de soltera que dijo no yo no quiero ir
yo todavía quiero casarme y tener hijos
tenía 34 años y yo pues me ofrecí nadie
quería ir a este lugar para ofrecer
evento musical me ofrecí porque conocía
su texto perfectamente y
[Música]
había también participado como
guitarrista fue la primera experiencia
que participe como actriz
y bueno nunca imaginé que
después
viajaría a méxico y en méxico me
esperaba más trabajo
no sé cuando pude grabar todos estos
discos más deben que componer dar
conciertos dar clases y estudiar idiomas
me acuerdo eran 30 horas de tomar 5
idiomas a la semana más aparte de dar
clases 25 horas
dar conciertos y por ahí también llevar
a mis tres hijos a la escuela y traerlos
porque mi esposo no maneja pero bueno ya
es otra historia yo misma le pedí que no
manejarán porque tuvimos un pequeño
accidente a unos días antes de casarnos
hace 30 años ya tengo un nieto
y bueno
no no sé cuando pude hacer todo esto
cuando pude preparar a los jóvenes
brillantes de la buap con un grupo de
maestros para que triunfarán en rúsia
2017 en 2018 pero lo único que aprendí
entre uno menos tiempo tiene más lo
aprovecho y para realizar todos esta
actividades pues son no tiene que estar
bien físicamente diario nos dicen hay
que hacer ejercicios a alimentarse bien
pero realmente es fundamental si hago
ejercicio tengo sueño
y es por eso es importante escoger algo
que les apasiona porque porque pues hay
que estar dispuesto también a sacrificar
muchas cosas a veces horas al sueño
aunque lo que sigue parece un programa
que advierte no lo hagas en casa pero
aprendí que si se puede recuperar las
fuerzas durmiendo una vez a la semana
domingo por ejemplo
parece dije no lo haga me encanta
y aparte del ejercicio físico pues es
importante también el ejercicio
intelectual y espiritual y de dónde
podemos encontrar
este ejercicio pues del acto está habido
que la música nos proporciona enormes
beneficios
desarrolla potenciales enormes y hacen
nuestra vida más plena más profunda más
intensa en la literatura podemos
encontrar mucha inspiración
no hay qué
esperar la inspiración hay que buscarlas
entonces la música nos desarrolla
habilidades lingüísticas lógico
matemáticas no se eleva autoestima
cuando un niño tiene problemas con
matemáticas hay que mandarlo a clases de
danza
es sabido que también muchos
investigadores lo han constatado que hay
que leer a los niños la poesía fomentar
el gusto por la poesía desde pequeños
aunque no la entiendan pero se van a
hacer preguntas sobre las metáforas y
ahí empieza el desarrollo del
pensamiento la policía es la
sensibilidad del pensamiento
la poesía es el pensamiento sensible
donde se une lo regional con la
intuición es el origen de la lengua es
la renovación de la lengua
les quiero leer un poema de josé luís
vega
poeta portorriqueño y claro les tocará
algo con la guitarra que ya se puso
celosa que no estoy tocando por eso la
comparan con la imagen de una mujer
celosa y caprichosa
exigente
sensible pero también es maravillosa
pero antes también
quisiera recalcar
algunas cosas
[Música]
no importa lo que te digan
lo que te digan de ti si tú crees en ti
puedes hacerlo
valora tu tiempo cuando menos lo tienes
isabel de tu zona de confort
busca la inspiración inspira a los demás
actúa
crea
bajo los efectos de la poesía es posible
viajar a la velocidad del pensamiento
mirar el mundo entero flamear tocar con
la punta de la lengua las estrellas
soñar con la justicia universal
bajo los efectos de la poesía usted no
es responsable de sus actos
hablara lengua extraña hará cúpulas
públicas cabalgar a centauros bajo los
efectos de la poesía se ven blancas
galaxias expandiéndose en el ojo de las
cerraduras y violines viejísimos mudando
el polvo de sus plumas no importa cuál
sea su pasión
sí
edad o ensoñación política no debe
avergonzarse de volar bajo los efectos
de la poesía
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sintiendo del mundo
usa
[Música]
solé azul
culminación de la creación
la forma del amor
[Música]
vuela hasta abrir con tus alas doradas
el universo en flor
[Música]
[Aplausos]